[Music]
thank you
hey everybody what's going on it's
Sunday
Khan says uh taking it way back to The
Honky silent movie era there's a concept
yeah it's like it's like it's like the
the Silver Screen Man back back white to
the silent era yes these these all have
sound back when you back when the United
States was purported to be white as snow
it wasn't it never was a lot of those
so-called white people were actually
Mexicans and stuff true and uh you had a
lot of mixed race people that uh came
across they were purported to be
Caucasian in a lot of these movies but
it was it was it's just [ __ ]
it was Show Business you know you were
you could be anything Karloff Karloff
wasn't a white guy he was mixed he was
white in English and and and and uh
Indian from India
but still
it was awesome that you know what I mean
it just he he could play any kind of
ethnic character he could do the mummy
and he could definitely do [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh Frankenstein
yeah you have to think that I mean he
was older like he was middle aged like
when he said he'd been in movies before
um but he wasn't a big star like he was
just kind of like a character actor he
was in like a lot of kind of crime like
Mar type of movies like always kind of
like Mexican yeah like things like that
something like that yeah but when he was
in Frankenstein I think he was in his
40s yeah um and this was like absolutely
his like breakout role and you know he
was just an icon like from the moment
this movie came out so we're going to
talk about Frankenstein and then Brian
fragrance so this is a twofer yeah and
uh was it was this the only Frankenstein
movie he was in or was he any other he
was in the third one which is son of
Frankenstein but that was the last one
that he was in I think after that like
Lon Chaney Jr took over and um then I
can't remember like well because there
was I think there was seven or eight
movies like in this particular cycle but
he was in the first three right these
are both good movies
um
Bride of Frankenstein being better A lot
of people say I'm gonna say that yeah
it's better it's kind of like the
difference between alien and Aliens
that's a good that's a good simile or
Terminator one Terminator two even
though I like Terminator one better but
um he's got a bigger part in it
Frankenstein's on screen more the
Frankenstein monsters on screen more a
lot of what he speaks there's a lot of
lines in it although Forest didn't like
that at first he didn't think the
monster should talk no he should have
talked I mean in the book He's talking
the book He's talking the book
and uh you you were it uh you were uh
eventually in the second one you were
introduced to a new villain and it's a
masterpiece I I actually prefer the
second one a lot of people do like I
said I'm not sure I will I kind of feel
like they're both good but I like that
they were I like that you're a simile of
like Alien Versus Aliens because it's
like they're clearly happening in the
same universe yeah but there's a lot of
difference but there's a lot of
differences but you can kind of take
both things so you know what I mean like
alien is like a horror movie and like
aliens is more like an action movie even
though they're kind of both along the
same lines that's kind of the same
Frankenstein the first one from 1931 is
much more like a very simple monster
movie
and I kind of feel like Bride of
Frankenstein is a lot more complex and
it's almost like a black comedy almost
it also looks a lot better it's a bigger
budget
um it's a lot more Gothic it's got a lot
of [ __ ] badass Gothic visual imagery
the shock composition is [ __ ] great
the acting's really good uh just it's a
much better movie the second one
I mean
you gotta [ __ ] the creature all right
Frankenstein's monster down in catacombs
yeah that was a great sequence bones
yeah talking to them it's just the way
the shit's shot the sets and everything
is just it's it's epic it looks like
Gothic postcards black and white
postcards what it looks like [ __ ]
really good the first one's good too but
the second one is a [ __ ] strong
strong response to the first one
uh and they added in a bunch of new
elements into it that were cool that
were still
kind of contemporary because not only
did they bring [ __ ] reanimated
corpses that that are alive they bring
in homunculus yeah all right which
that's another thing that they believe
did back then or they were theorized it
was like from horror sci-fi where a man
could take his sperm and bring that to
life yeah they couldn't say that word he
said seed he called it seed Dr pretorius
this isn't Bride of Frankenstein the
dude's messing with their seed and I'm
like oh and making little creatures out
of them put them in jars making little
kings and queens
ballerina hotties and [ __ ] so weird some
weird [ __ ]
you had a dude who was into messing with
his seed hooking up you could call it
what it is [ __ ] and he and he's he's
shown as kind of a [ __ ] pervert you
know they kind of pretend you're a
perverted [ __ ] where they were
portrayed him and he's hooking up with
Dr Frankenstein and together they're
gonna make a new super race and that's
in the second one so it went from Alien
to alien the ends in the [ __ ] in the
second one kind of did yeah I liked it I
like the second one I gotta see the
third one we're gonna see the third one
we'll do a video yeah I've heard Center
I don't think I've seen Senator
Frankenstein or if I have I was a kid
but a lot of people like this the the
third one as well like I think after
that they kind of started to go downhill
well because the Boris Karloff didn't
play the Monster like after the third
one you gotta have Carla I mean I'm not
and I'm not [ __ ] on like other
people that played Frankenstein sponsor
because I have Billy Lugosi played him
uh later on I think in the Abbott
Costello one and [ __ ] like that but I
mean Boris Karloff is just kind of like
he owns that [ __ ] role yeah he owns
it and a lot of the imagery of [ __ ]
the creature or Frankenstein's monster
going through like
cemeteries with [ __ ] you know what I
mean with with
headstones with crosses and all the
imagery that you think of when you think
of Frankenstein it was from the second
movie not so much the first the first
was good but a lot of the really good
imagery came from the second one
yeah I do kind of feel like
um like I said I think there's like a
lot of because I was watching like other
people's
um you know reviews about of these
movies and stuff like that but a lot of
people really do like Bride of
Frankenstein better like they're where
they're saying that it's like this is
one of the rare cases where the sequel
is better than the original but like I
said it is
a slightly different tone I kind of feel
like the first one like I said was more
like a straight up horror monster movie
like so it was a lot more serious and
you didn't really get to
I mean even though Frankenstein's
monster and the first one was
sympathetic uh you know in much the same
way that King Kong was for example
um because he doesn't talk like you
can't really get to know him as a
character he's just kind of like a force
of nature a little bit even though like
I said you do feel bad for him whereas
in the second one I kind of feel like
you have a lot more sympathy for him
even though he kills a lot more people
um just because he talks and you can see
that he's just so angry at like everyone
like [ __ ] with him constantly so you
can't really blame him for being pissed
off and killing people because
everyone's kind of dicks he's he's a
sympathetic guy
Frankenstein sponsor yeah he's
sympathetic yeah I mean they were
[ __ ] with him and he didn't ask for
anything sewn together out of corpses
man it was just kind of like
he's a good character you know what I'm
saying yeah and then the second one when
they bring in the bride
the bride was cool too but my my big
[ __ ] knock against the second one is
that the bride
was not on screen for very long yeah
she's mentioned it for like a minute and
she ends up getting killed
and she wasn't in any of the sequels
like they never brought her back yeah it
should never have done it because it's a
great idea I mean character look it's
just so [ __ ] awesome it was a [ __ ]
fantastic character you could have
spin-offs and everything using that
character but they didn't quite think
that way back then
they tried to wrap everything up
but you in the second one you had a
situation where you had two perverted
Geniuses saying well we're going to make
a woman this time
and they use the bones of a [ __ ]
evidently the strong bones of a hot 18
year old died firm they were firm firm
strong
of a hot 18 year old girl who died in
the late 1800s they're going to use that
and they wrapped a bunch of Flesh around
it using us an artificial brain
and with the heart of a hooker
I mean the implication it was a heart of
a hook that I mean because Fritz like
the assistant he just went out there and
grabbed grabbed her off the street yeah
so I'm assuming that in a movie of this
silk like any woman that was walking
around the streets alone at that time of
night was probably a prostitute it's a
man's fantasy going back to the [ __ ]
30s you make your own woman just made
the order okay she's [ __ ] built on
the [ __ ] structure of an 18 year old
hot as hell an AI an artificially
intelligent brain heart of a hoe and
[ __ ] and she comes out she's got boob
Shadow and everything
her [ __ ] hair and she loves you when
she comes out but it goes wrong it goes
wrong
and she's Savage and she yeah it [ __ ]
and they should have never killed that
character but they didn't understand
branding back then they they didn't see
the potential
I mean they did in the Frankenstein's
monster because he was in like a [ __ ]
out of movies he's like how that broad
could have made him a lot of money well
that's the thing and it's like man that
could have been it's a whole own
spin-off exactly exactly maybe they just
didn't think about it because she was
just kind of like oh bride of friends
like she was like an adjunct yeah he's
just yeah but she's just a woman dude
that's just a woman dudes would have
paid to see that [ __ ] all [ __ ] day
but I mean I think it's kind of
emblematic like the [ __ ] uh you know
uh the the way the impact that she made
literally if you say the movie's called
The Bride of Frankenstein and like Elsa
Lanchester and the hair is like all over
the poster even though she's literally
all in the movie for like maybe two
minutes like toward the end most of it
is about Dr pretorius and Dr
Frankenstein and then like you know
Frankenstein's monster Boris Karloff
doing his Rampage or whatever trying to
make friends and all that so you
literally don't see her until the very
very end and then like she's immediately
like killed off like within two minutes
and it's compelling you're like yeah wow
I mean
you should have never killed that
character dumb idea very the only thing
similar to that would have been the
species species the movie Species yeah
with Natasha Hansford yeah that was a
similar concept and the other one was
one of the space vampires what was the
one uh life force life force the Toby
Hooper yeah Toby Hooper great movie if
you haven't it's a great movie so weird
as [ __ ] those are the only two movies
that kind of had that female horror sex
element and they came they got it they
got it that was it and they threw it
away
they I don't understand Elsa Lanchester
was like cute as [ __ ] yeah they got and
well the thing is I'm not sure if you
haven't seen it in a long time
um she's not just the Bride of
Frankenstein she also plays Mary Shelley
like at the beginning because for
whatever reason I'm not really sure why
they decided to do this but there's kind
of like a little prologue which is her
and Percy Shelley and Lord Byron and
they're talking about I guess it was
kind of a way because there was four
years I think like in between because
Frankenstein the first one came out in
1931 and then the second one didn't come
out till 1935. so it wasn't like you
could just like watch the old one like
before you saw the new one you know what
I mean it didn't work like that back
then so they had to like recap what had
happened at the first one because the
second one starts like right pretty much
right where the first one ended
so they have like a little prologue
where she's being Mary Shelley and Lord
Byron is like why don't you tell us the
rest of that story that you were talking
about and she's like oh well here's
let's catch everybody up with what
happened in the first movie in case you
don't remember and then she's like and
then this happened you know what I mean
so and then they kind of like you know
but um yeah so she gets to be in it
and interestingly they they credit her
like in the credits as Mary Shelley but
then like as the monsters mate like
they'd put a question mark just like
they did at the beginning of the first
Frankenstein when they didn't want you
to know like who the monster was like
they put Boris Carl off at the end like
in the end credits but they didn't put
it in the beginning Khan is commenting
on the shirt saying he may get something
like that look if you want one of these
shirts uh go ahead and send me a private
message we'll we'll hook something up
and uh also said that's a new shirt may
I see to you yeah yeah but uh
no if you want an Omega Man shirt just
send me a private message we'll work it
out I'll send it to you know
sleeve any any size or style you want
good I can hook you up
but no uh yeah they should have never
thrown that fried character away you
could have gotten two or three movies
out of that easily
two or three more
you just have to play it the right way
yeah like I said that would have been a
totally cool and it's weird too because
people would have went to see it they
would if Frankenstein though is one that
they haven't even like remade no I don't
even think Hammer didn't do one did
hammer do one no they did their own
frankincense
yeah but that was not yeah yeah we
talked about that one from the 80s but
it's like that's not exactly
you need to go straight bride
you know yeah I'm just surprised a lot
and you have to and she gotta look like
that you gotta look like that I want
like that iconic look and she's got to
be because she looked normal she's got
to be Undead like Frankenstein she has
to be femi as [ __ ] see that would kick
out and dudes are trying to get in it
and [ __ ] and then she's got all these
problems about being being basically an
undead sex bot and then getting getting
Vengeance or somehow coming into her own
but I mean behind that honestly the
closest movie that's been made like was
maybe like frankenhooker frankenhooker
which sounds crazy but yeah yeah
frankenhooker is like kind of like a
yeah I mean there was bride of
reanimator like somebody mentioned
reanimator which is like of yeah I mean
reanimator is like a Frankenstein story
even though it's based on uh Loosely
based on H.P Lovecraft story
um but it also has elements of your
concern I I think if you're gonna do
Brian Frankenstein it has to be in the
same Spirit of this movie and then cat
people kind of mixed in together yeah do
something like cat people it's got to be
a chick flick but a horror flick at the
same time yeah because cat people she
was a monster too even though she looked
regular she's right like she just like
turned in and she has to re come to
realize that she's a sentient being but
she was made to basically be a [ __ ]
sex pot you know well yeah that's what
they just made her because they wanted
to like a beautiful woman well they
wanted her to breed with Frankenstein's
monster and they could make like uh a
race of people yeah you know what I mean
they don't come out and say she has the
[ __ ] heart of a hooker but dude
killed a woman who was walking around in
the middle of the night
and it's implied that she was a hooker
the heart I mean that was the
implication yeah it's that that for the
for the time that would never fit yeah
or like okay yeah she's like a hooker
well the thing about it I kind of
thought too when they're like hey we
well because the first heart that they
got like wasn't working out so they're
like okay well we need you Fritz to go
although I think they it was the same
actor it was Dwight Frye who
incidentally was the same guy that
played Renfield in the Dracula movie
like with Bella go see but he was in the
first movie as Fritz the assistant he's
also in the second movie but Fritz got
killed in the first one so they call him
Carl in this one even though it's
clearly the same dude although he
doesn't have like a hunchback or
anything so they basically tell him well
we need you to go out to and get us
another heart because this one's not
working and I was like oh I'll just pop
down to the 24-hour heart Mart and like
pick you up one but they kind of then
they show him like kind of skulking
around in an alley and like throwing a
hood over this woman's head and then
like they don't show what happens to it
so I'm assuming and they they didn't
straight up tell him hey go out and kill
somebody I think they were expecting him
to like go rob a [ __ ] you know a
hospital or something like that you know
what I mean I don't think they like
legit told him because I when he came
back and he's just like oh it's real
fresh and they were like what do you
mean you know what I mean it's like that
um I killed somebody I just you know
what I mean I can't hate him a certain
amount of crowds right so he's like a
thousand crowns wouldn't it yeah I think
it was a thousand crowns which I don't
know how much the money that is but it's
apparently ten thousand dollars that's
apparently a lot yeah go get us a heart
yeah they didn't really say not she got
out of them buddy got it out of a lone
woman in Bavaria walking around at night
in the middle of the [ __ ] City and in
in the days that they're talking about
that would have been a hooker that's
what they're talking about
yeah slasher friend said Fritz picks the
Abbey normal brain yeah that's the funny
thing like in the first movie
um you think because if all you've seen
is Young Frankenstein you know like the
Mel Brooks like parody of Frankenstein
you kind of think that that whole normal
brain Abby normal brain like Abby
someone uh you kind of think that's a
joke but that actually does happen in
the first movie like you know Fritz goes
to get the brain and he picks up the
normal brain that's just been left there
like after an anatomy class like
conveniently and he drops it and he's
like oh [ __ ] so then he just goes
against the other one it like doesn't
tell so it's like in in Young
Frankenstein it's like it's funny but
it's like not a joke because that's
exactly what happens in the first movie
they didn't even like really exaggerate
it so you want to start with the first
movie do you have all the stuff for that
one yeah I mean we're just kind of it's
just kind of like a loose we're just
kind of like a loose I didn't want it to
be like they're both good movies but I'm
gonna give it to the second one the
second one's a lot better
now it's more of what you would consider
everything you think of Frankenstein and
Frankenstein's monster comes more from
the second movie than the first one the
first one is kind of there's a lot of
dialogue in it it's kind of basic
uh the second one's a lot better there's
a lot more on-screen action
the imagery is a lot better
uh the budget is bigger
they're like I said they're both good
but that second one [ __ ] blows it
blows the first one out of the water if
you ask me it just looks a lot better I
think they're mostly the reason that
I've seen people um that prefer the
first one to the second one which like I
said there's nothing wrong with that
opinion either I think I slightly prefer
the second one but I can see why people
would like the first one better most
people that prefer the first one they
don't like
um like the humor or the camp Factor
like in the second one yeah which I can
see that because a little bit now I will
say that one character like that older
woman that's always like shrieking and
yeah yeah yeah and [ __ ] like that
comedic relief yeah she's like she's
kind of annoying but I mean she's kind
of funny though like at the same time
what's funny is that they keep showing
her as it's like a old hag but you look
at her now and like because I saw this
when I was a kid it made an impression
on me certain scenes like where they
have [ __ ] dry they have [ __ ]
Frankenstein's monster chained up in the
dungeon and everything I remember that
when I was a kid but what was funny
about this is that
when I was a little kid I thought it was
like yeah crazy old lady you look at her
now she's maybe 40. yeah she's not that
old she's like maybe 45. she's not an
old lady she's she's they're making her
look older but she's not an older she's
actually kind of cute you know in a way
if you saw her just walking around and
she's being normal she'd just be a cute
middle-aged woman but it's kind of funny
to see her
do her little [ __ ] thing now you know
because as a kid I remember and I
remember her looking being an old lady
but she's she's not an old lady she's
not really that old no when you look at
her no she's pretending to be an old
like crazy old lady I think she played a
very similar character in The Invisible
Man now that I'm thinking about yeah I
haven't seen that which was a couple
years before that you got to see the
Invisible Man got to see Wolf Man gotta
see um yeah we're trying to like watch
all the universe gotta see the [ __ ]
Creature from the Black Lagoon yeah okay
now as far as Boris Karloff goes and and
karloff's work
I'm gonna give it I'm gonna give it more
to the mummy The Mummy has a lot there's
a there's a lot more to the mummy in
terms of speaking lines that Karloff has
and uh Black Cat the black cat with
[ __ ] bellagosi those are still
I think kinda
in some ways Superior movies in terms of
like his acting role in it I mean don't
get me wrong he does a great job as the
monster
he does have some speaking lines in it
in the second one in the second one not
in the first one that's the first one
but the um
visually
bride of Frankenstein's [ __ ]
fantastic I mean it just knocks it out
of the park it's better than the mummy
but in terms of uh can just
dialogue and story
the mommy if you're talking about
Karloff and his work I would say the
mummy
that's yeah that's his movie he carries
that [ __ ] mood
yeah it doesn't quite visually look as
cool as [ __ ] the bride the Brian
Frankenstein [ __ ] him
visually you know what's really
interesting about the makeup like the
Frankenstein's monster makeup in both
the movies like I mean the original 1931
Frankenstein uh you know the makeup
obviously by Jack Pierce is like he also
did The Mummy by the way which we talked
about the other day but um is Iconic the
thing about it it looks a little bit
different in the second one and that's
because I didn't actually really notice
this until I delved a little bit into
the backstory behind it they said they
wanted the monster in the second one
well one he couldn't um he had to like
uh I think in the first one he had like
some things in his mouth like to make
his cheeks look more sunken in and in
the second one since he was going to be
talking like they couldn't have that so
he didn't have like those sunken cheeks
like in the first one but also in the
second one they wanted it to look like
he'd been in a fire
so they made it so that like most of his
hair was burned off if you noticed that
like he didn't have like as much hair in
the as in the first one and also there
was like you could see like the little
metal rivets like where the skull was
held together like these kind of little
metal things like that as though part of
the hair had burned away like part of
the skin had burned away and now you
could see that and they said as the
movie went on
um it looked like his face was like
healing up from him like being in the
fire and like all the [ __ ] that happened
to him and everything so it's like that
kind of like attention to detail that's
like really really amazing you have to
say but yeah so when Boris Karloff when
they asked him to do Bride of
Frankenstein and they told him well
Brian Frankenstein it you know the
monster's gonna talk he was not a fan of
that idea he didn't he didn't think that
um the the mods would be scary if he
talked and he just didn't like it but I
mean I guess James whale was like pretty
insistent and like I said the monster
does talk in the book in the book The
Monster actually like this is eloquent
learns to talk and yeah it's like really
eloquent like finds like some books or
something like that and like teach like
reads Paradise Lost and [ __ ] like that
so he's like real like philosophical
which I don't think that would work like
with the character that they've
established but the fact that they made
him like more a character
and kind of like they said we wanted him
to be kind of like a kid you know what I
mean so they said that they studied like
um 10 year olds and like their uh you
know they're kind of like vocabulary
like words that they would use and they
wanted him to be like that like use the
same vocabulary as like a 10 year old
kid how how this movie ends in terms of
uh the bride or the pride of
Frankenstein
um
the creature actually ends up being a
hero
Spence is Justice he destroys evil and
he uh he lets Dr Frankenstein and his
wife go yeah you can go which that
didn't happen in the book it didn't
happen in the book but he kills the wife
in the book right and the reason why I
did that is because uh in this movie
is because uh Dr Frankenstein himself
did not want to do it did not want to
make the bride he was forced into it uh
Dr pretorius made him do it
so the monster didn't hold him
responsible for it and the in this when
the monster destroys himself Dr
pretorius and the bride yeah because he
said that they weren't basically weren't
fit and Carl and yeah and Carl but that
[ __ ] really
he survived it anyway because there's
the third movie well yeah
so it's a little bit of an empty gesture
yeah he just tried he tried to erase it
which that's not really how it would
have gone down in the book uh in the
book the mo the the monster would have
tried to kill Dr [ __ ] Frankenstein
too for for making him yeah which is
yeah because that was combination kind
of the whole going against God point of
the thing yeah and like I think slasher
Fred like or somebody like uh pointed
out earlier that there was actually when
the movie The First movie Frankenstein
came out which was a massive hit it will
I mean universal had been like in a lot
of financial trouble prior to Dracula
coming out and Dracula was such a
massive hit that they're like oh [ __ ] we
need to make a horror movie like right
now because you know we're making all
this money so that's when Frankenstein
came along so they're like oh well we
need to do an adaptation of Frankenstein
but they actually did a Frank did an
adaptation not so much of the novel but
much like they did with Dracula it was
like a stage play like I think a stage
play had come out like in the 8 1830s
1839 something like well Mary Shelley
was still alive like she did actually
see the stage play version of it but
they had been you know that had kind of
been going around and they kind of based
the screenplay on that so the first
Frankenstein movie is I was reading the
thing that it said maybe 15 of the book
is kind of like what's in the movie not
much there you have um Bride of
Frankenstein believe it or not is
actually more faithful to the book but
there's still like a lot of [ __ ] in
there that doesn't happen like the like
in Bride of Frankenstein like the stuff
with the blind man and stuff with the
stuff with you know him making the a
mate for the monster like the monster
wanting a mate that's all in the book
but there's a lot of stuff that's like
added but there's been a lot of stuff
like added from the first one too
because you know in the book Dr
Frankenstein they there's not like all
you know like the the Mad Science type
of thing with all the like uh you know
the the gadgets and all that kind of
stuff that's not in the book like
basically the book doesn't really say
like how exactly he creates the whole
guy it was kind of like an Alchemy kind
of situation the whole Blind Man scene
was choking me up when I was a kid I
remember seeing it's so sad you're like
oh yeah [ __ ] uh the blind man scene
makes the movie that should have been in
the first movie I thought it was in the
first movie I did too I forgot now
Frankenstein's monster like throwing the
little girl that's enough into the pond
like thinking that she'll float and like
accidentally kill him I've heard that's
in the first movie that's the first
movie I thought the blind bam thing was
in the first movie too but it's not
enough
you're right but that's the thing in the
book
um you know Frankenstein
the reason that he kills the reason that
the monster kills Frankenstein's wife
Elizabeth is because Frankenstein
because in the book of Dr pretorius I
don't think is in the book no Dr
Frankenstein is just basically like okay
well I'm gonna make a mate for the
monster because he's gonna [ __ ] with me
if I don't and so he does it but then he
realizes oh [ __ ] shouldn't have done
that and he destroys her and then the
monster gets mad and is like [ __ ] you
and your wife and kills the wife like in
retaliation like because he because he
didn't go through with it did Dr
pretorius character I thought was a good
move uh he's so great in this is he like
the movie choose all the scenery up and
yeah and it's glory it was a good idea
to put him in the second movie so
there's so there's a second villain a
real villain to take the load off of the
monster all right because the monster is
not truly a villain really he's scary
he's a threat
but the real villain is Dr pretorius in
this one yeah and he's a perverted Evil
Genius all right and the guy playing him
is [ __ ] fantastic his dialogue's
fantastic he's a [ __ ] pimp he's
[ __ ] uh he's pimp he's he's [ __ ]
he's a great character he's twisting
everybody's minds and getting the
[ __ ] monster to do what he wants to
[ __ ] pipping his ass out it's [ __ ]
funny and uh but he's evil he's kind of
and the casting was good he's kind of
like a uh
kind of like a
[ __ ] Peter Murphy he's got like an
old Peter Murphy an old skinny Peter
Murphy
funeral
bubble gut [ __ ] but well he used
to be skinny yeah yeah
long nose and [ __ ] he looks great on
camera and he's just he's a good
character
um
I recommend both movies you want to you
kind of want to see them both they're
not long either the first one isn't long
the second one's a little bit longer
they're about the same I think one of
them is an hour and 13 minutes and one's
an hour and 14 minutes or an hour and 19
minutes or something like that they're
both really short you could easily watch
them back to back yeah they're they're
they're not yeah something you'd watch
like on a [ __ ] rainy night while
you're having a drink you got to slow
yourself down it was another era back
then
um but they're they're cool and I I for
me I like the second one the second one
was also packed with hotties there's a
lot of 1930s hot hotties in there and
they were big into glamor all right and
uh the Glamor Shots the hair the outfits
um they were sexy but it was a different
kind of it wasn't in your face it was
kind of a subtle
they knew what to do with Shadow and
costumes
because you know they weren't going to
show nudity but they were going to try
to show you nudity and they did that
even with the bride
when the bride is on her table and they
[ __ ] stand her up she's in all these
like mummy wrappings and they got the
shadow just perfect so they could give
so they can show you her
very feminine figure so her boobs and
her boobs [ __ ] she had boobs Shadow and
everything and they're letting you know
that these perverted [ __ ] have
made a sex toy really is what is is what
they've done which is what what dudes
would do that's what they would do yeah
and uh spot on they're gonna make a
woman she's gonna be [ __ ] hot they
even put the heart of a hooker in it and
a [ __ ] not a real they didn't realize
I don't think but that's the way that
that's what they wanted that's the the
directors are in on this too and then
the the brain wasn't even a real brain
it was a synthetic brain
that [ __ ] Dr pretorius and it made
somehow somehow that wasn't explained it
was just a brain I kind of thought and
maybe this is maybe I'm just talking out
my ass but I thought the implication was
that Dr pretorius because he came in and
he showed the whole homunculus that like
all the stuff that he had in jars like
all those little people like yeah that
could have been just to like show off
the like awesome special effects and the
special effects on this are really
really good for 1935. but I mean George
melier had done some of that stuff like
in the silent movies like with little
tiny people and jars and stuff but um
they look great here I kind of thought
that the implication was that Dr
pretorius was more of like a black magic
Alchemy type of guy yeah Alchemy like
who was like not really Ray was not
really saying like how he was doing it's
not science right and then he was kind
of like approaching and that's why he
wanted to team up with Dr Frankenstein
because Dr Frankenstein was coming at it
from a more scientific standpoint with
like electricity and all of that it was
science and black magic coming in right
that's kind of what they didn't like say
that explicitly but I thought that that
was implicit it's implied yeah that's
what I thought and and the sexual
elements are implied big time uh well
glorious is messing with his [ __ ] yeah
making creatures okay well like I said
I kind of feel like from a modern
standpoint I'm you know I'm not sure how
much you guys I think most people know
but like James whale the director of
both these movies was one of the first
openly gay men like in Hollywood like he
didn't make a secret about it so a lot
of people have read not so much the
first movie but uh for sure the second
movie as kind of like having like a
queer subtext which is probably a lot
clearer nowadays than it would have been
back then well the blind hermit that's
that's kind of a gay subtext there yeah
I mean for a friend and I can't see you
and it doesn't it's not physical it's
it's mental I don't care and I was kind
of thinking too like the relationship
between Dr Frankenstein and Dr pretorius
because they're essentially I mean they
want to I I saw something
um or I read something where it was
pointed out that Dr pretorius literally
shows up like you know and pulls Dr
Frankenstein like out of his bed like
away from his wife to go do [ __ ] with
him you know what I mean so there's a
lot of that kind of stuff gay male
Supremacy it is right I do kind of feel
like and I don't I don't know if like
James whale would have like read it that
way but it does kind of like come across
a little bit it does kind of come across
like that a little bit I was reading
that into the into the uh to Blind
Hermit the whole blind hermit thing come
here now he'll feed you now get into my
bed and then he's praying over him and
everything and it's just yeah
it's and then a friend just to make a
friend friend
yeah
yeah fire good and bad yeah yeah he
tried it he tried to teach you all that
the thing is though it's it's it's
that's a touching scene and it is that's
like that [ __ ] shut up and [ __ ]
it up for everybody one of those dudes
was John Carradine did you realize no I
didn't know that yeah I didn't realize
that either until I like looked at the
at the list and the hermit was like but
he's my friend and remember he went down
to he never turned on on Frankenstein no
he never turned on him even though they
said this is the [ __ ] he's made
out of dead people yeah and he's gonna
run around killing everybody though but
he's like yeah but he's my friend he's
like he hasn't like done anything you
guys are just being dicks to him that's
why you like that yeah you guys did it
so that that kind of [ __ ] is what made
me think that the second one's better
the second one's a better writing it
looks better better budget
and um yeah you need the first one to
get the story started
but the second one [ __ ] tops it off
but like I said the second one is a lot
more complex the first one's good if
it's just like a simple monster movie
yeah and I don't know I kind of slightly
prefer even though like I said you know
the monster is still sympathetic like I
kind of liked it when he wasn't talking
and I liked like his look better in the
first one but the second one I think
like objectively probably is like a
better movie overall what's the matter
she's yawning and yelling
um yeah slasher friends that I read that
Frankenstein's line I know what it's
like to be God and the scene where the
monster accidentally kills the young
girl were originally cut from you know
the original yes they were uh there was
actually a lot of stuff cut out
um when the movie was first released
because you have to think this was 1931
okay they were they were very sensitive
and um I read that like a couple of
states in the U.S like Kansas
specifically they wanted to like cut out
half the movie because they just thought
it was like too [ __ ] upsetting but
one of the things that got cut out was
him throwing the little girl into the
water they've since restored it
um you know that scene but the thing
about it here's what's ironic about that
scene
the scene where he picks her up because
he doesn't mean to he doesn't know that
she's gonna drown he's like oh the
flowers float maybe she'll float too and
she throws it in there it's like it's
not his fault he's not malicious I mean
she's still dead but you know he's not
malicious he's an accident so yeah so
the fact that they took that out but
then they left in the subsequent scene
where the little girl's dad is carrying
her dead body through the streets and
she looks like all [ __ ] [ __ ] up and
you're not really sure what happened I'm
like that kind of makes it seem worse
yeah like he raped her or something
right that's what I mean it's like I so
I think like the implication that was
left by taking that one seed out like
made it look even worse than it actually
was you know what I mean and they did
take out the the scene where he's and
it's back in there now like I said if
you watch it on 2B or wherever you watch
it like the the line where
um Colin Clive says you know now I know
what it's like to be God because after
he brings the monster to life yeah they
took that part they took that out too
because they thought it was sacrilegious
but you know it's all been restored now
which is good because back in the 1930s
like I said I don't think they have the
same uh understanding of like film maybe
like as an art form like at least in
general so like when they cut stuff out
of movies they tend to just like cut
stuff out and like Chuck it away or like
whatever so they didn't like save it or
nothing so it was good that they
actually like still found those scenes
that had been cut out and were able to
restore them because that would have
been a real bummer if they'd been gone
forever uh Last Avenger 85 said Hammer
did Frankenstein created woman oh that's
right I totally forgot about it yeah
there's a bunch of spin-offs I was gonna
say that there had to be a hammer one
because they kind of went and I'd
forgotten about that one I saw it a long
time ago so far as far as Frankenstein's
stories
uh compared to Mary Shelley's book from
what I remember I read it a long time
ago I would say that um
Frankenstein Robert De Niro's
Frankenstein is the closest to the book
from what I remember yeah we reviewed
that not too long ago but yeah that's
the most faithful one the Kenneth Brana
director and it's a good movie it even
has the bride in it if I remember
correctly what yeah she was it yeah and
that's that's basically just basically
the story
um but there's something about Bride of
Frankenstein the second one from this
series
visually
and knocks it out of the park man I love
that scene in the Crypt yeah I mean the
blind man scene I think is the best
thing in the movie but that scene where
they're in the Crypt and like shots in
there and he comes across Dr pretorius
like Dr pretorius they're like drinking
wine like because he's like a weird
pervert and he's like in there like
drinking to a skull and like hanging out
in the Crypt and all this other [ __ ]
inside shots the interior shots of
Castle Frankenstein with the Vols to the
ceilings I mean [ __ ] no man yeah and
then the shots of [ __ ] the
Frankenstein's monster going through the
cemetery at night people chasing him and
all the damn
all the damn [ __ ] gravestones and
[ __ ] sarcophagus and [ __ ] it's just
visually Gothic as [ __ ] it really is
yeah Gothic as [ __ ] more Gothic than
belugosi's [ __ ] Dracula
it's more Gothic yeah it's I mean I love
the original Dracula we should probably
cover that one day too that's also on
Tubi yeah but I kind of feel like and as
a whole I think as a novel I like
Dracula a little bit better than
Frankenstein although I think both
novels are are great but I think the
movies of Frankenstein at least the
first two are a lot more action-packed
like Dracula is a little bit slow moving
yeah a little bit you can tell that's a
stage play right on film well the thing
about it is that the original
Frankenstein from 1931 that was based on
a stage play too but it's a lot more
like I said it's just like a monster
movie it's more obviously a monster
movie than Dracula is because Dracula is
more like a character but I mean for
most of Dracula you're kind of following
like the you know the other characters
which I guess you kind of are in
Frankenstein too but I don't know just I
guess because the doctor is such an
iconic character because the doctor is
like a [ __ ] nut too yeah hey stop it
knock it off folk she turned the walls
up yeah stop it stop tearing it up she's
like what I wasn't doing it what
well and that's the thing too is that in
the novel essentially I mean Dr
Frankenstein the doctor is really the
monster yeah I mean really the real
monster he's the real monster yeah so
they actually like in the movies they
actually make him not as monstrous and I
think in Bride of Frankenstein them
introducing the doctor pretorius
character who is clearly a villain
um kind of lets Dr Frankenstein off the
hook a little bit it does because Dr
Frankenstein like at the end of the
first movie like you know the the
monster kind of throws him off the mill
and like you think he's dead but he's
all right like he's kind of allowed to
get away his wife gets away she's fine
and all this other kind of [ __ ] but they
think that the monster is dead so then
when the monster comes back like he's
kind of like horrified and he feels
really bad and he only makes the bride
because Dr pretorius essentially like
gets the monster to like blackmail him
and said hey we're gonna kidnap your
wife Elizabeth unless you make the
creature but so he kind of has to or
they're gonna kill his wife you know
what I mean so he's like a lot more
sympathetic character whereas in the
book He's not evil but he's an anti-hero
he's an anti-hero he's that he's not a
villain but right if you're not going to
read the book see the Robert De Niro
Frankenstein in that one that's pretty
close to the book Dr Frankenstein is a
sympathetic feeling okay
the creature
is an anti-hero
I mean he got [ __ ] over but he commits
murders too he's not a good guy yeah
he's not commits murders and then pins
them out other people
yeah he's a lot more sophisticated in
the book yeah like he lets that innocent
woman get hanged right for [ __ ] that he
did for something that he did you're
right he did it on purpose to punish Dr
Frankenstein right for making it and he
kills that kid he kills uh Dr
Frankenstein's brother like who's like a
kid he breaks his neck he's kind of like
a tragic anti-hero yeah uh
Frankenstein's Creed Frankenstein's
monster but Dr Frankenstein and Michelle
Dr Frankenstein himself is basically a
villain yeah
sympathetic but still a villain he
shouldn't have defied God is the moral
of the story
in God's domain
for selfish purposes for selfish reasons
and [ __ ] that and that [ __ ] happened
to him and he should have known better
that's the moral morality tale he's
trying to use this very shallots of God
Mary Shelley is trying to tell you a
morality tale yeah okay and
um but no they're all good we're gonna
see more a lot more I want to see some
Italian spin-offs I'm on I'm on the
Frankenstein trip now yeah because
somebody's talking about lady
Frankenstein oh yeah I'm on the
Frankenstein trip we'll watch them uh
gotta see the cree Gotta See Creature
from the Black Lagoon Gotta See Wolfman
I've never seen uh Wolf Man the original
Wolfman never seen it I saw it but a
long time ago well that's kind of the
cool thing I think um 2B has a
surprising number of the original
Universal movies which is cool like I
said they have Dracula that Frankenstein
they Bride of Frankenstein I think they
might have set up Frank said they have
son of Dracula they have um Creature
from the Black Lagoon uh revenge of the
creature they have a [ __ ] ton somebody
mentioned the old dark house which is
another one that I've been wanting to
see that Boris Karloff is in that as
well
um shutter has that I think but I think
it's on some other streaming services as
well that's another one that I want to
do yeah I'm kind of like getting into
this hole because remember we talked
about before I was like you know I you
know I really like to do like new horror
movies and stuff like that and stuff
from the 70s and 80s but we've covered
so much stuff that I feel like there's a
big gap well these old ones are so old
that they're kind of new to a lot of
people if you're a lot of young people
even people RH have never seen these
they're good you should see them
they're not
I wouldn't say they're scary
they're not scary not by today's
standards they are creepy you have to
think about it a little bit more because
there's a lot of subtext
that they're talking about yeah because
there's a lot of stuff they couldn't say
you say it because they get [ __ ] [ __ ]
canned they get censored yeah so there's
a bunch of subtext about what's
happening and the the the traditional
Universal Studios monster movies
uh uh within reason you know once you go
down to [ __ ] part five and [ __ ] you
know right but that's true that's true
everything yeah they were good real good
they were artistic and a lot of [ __ ] was
shot we we want to do belugosi's [ __ ]
Dracula yeah because that's that's
definitely last night that's a good one
okay
um man when I was a little kid I saw
this [ __ ] on television
and it blew me a [ __ ] way I've seen
it lots of times I've probably seen it
more than the original Frankenstein
actually because it seemed like it was
always on it would show that early in
the morning right after the cartoons
you know I was a kid I saw that [ __ ]
blue when [ __ ] Bella goes come here
whoa we use mind powers on the dude
right they don't show a lot it's just a
lot of dialogue and even as a kid it was
it was tripping me the [ __ ] out you know
now
everybody wanted sequels and part three
and yeah it got better and sometimes it
got ludicrous but I haven't seen it in a
long time I'll give you a more modern
opinion on it as I see him
um because they tried to reboot Dracula
over and over again it Dracula the
Dracula movie was not really set up for
a sequel it just wasn't
so spoofy self-contained yeah and people
wanted more so they had to figure out
how they were going to give you more and
then there was copywriting involved so
they couldn't give you more sometimes
you know
but uh definitely see Frankenstein one
and two
and we're gonna do three here soon I'll
tell you yeah I've heard like I said I
don't think I've seen son of
Frankenstein since I was a kid yeah but
I've heard that a lot of people really
like that one too but like I said it's
after that I'm pretty sure like it kind
of like the quality fell off because
Boris Karloff wasn't playing the monster
anymore like after the third one but you
know it's I mean famously somebody
brought this up earlier
um they did ask Bella Lugosi to be the
monster in this little bitty Bill to go
see compared to yeah well I mean like I
said he did play the the monster like in
another movie later on why Bella well
because he was the he was a big star at
that yeah because he'd just been in
Dracula and he kind of like saved the
studio
um but the thing about Boris Karloff I
think James whale like saw Boris Karloff
like in a in a crime movie and said ooh
that dude's got a great face yeah uh you
know for a monster and he's like a much
more hulking like imposing presence
especially when they put all the stuff
on him but
um yeah Bella guys there's kind of
different stories going around it's just
kind of like I think the the most
popular story is that they offered Bella
Lugosi the role of the monster and he's
like no I don't want to do it because
it's just kind of like you know one you
won't be able to see my face and two
there's no lines and it wasn't really
his kind of thing you know what I mean
um but some people said that that's not
true that some people uh that James will
was like no they wanted Boris Karloff
all along so I'm not really sure like
which one is true
Bella Bella was the quintessential
[ __ ] Dracula yeah okay that that was
he that that was him
but in the black cat man he played Vitus
veltagast which is a dude that has had
[ __ ] survived the [ __ ] First World
War I think it was
and uh was [ __ ] going back to find
his old commander who was turned out it
was a Satanist who
sacrifice the whole [ __ ] unit and
Vitus had come out of the [ __ ] cool
Gaul which is like a [ __ ]
concentration camp you guys got to see
black cat the original Boris Karloff
belugosi
baylock could do a [ __ ] awesome role
it didn't have to be Dracula
you know you could put him in some [ __ ]
he was [ __ ] creepy I'm pretty sure in
one of the later Frankenstein movies he
played Igor
yeah okay
in either son of Frankenstein or the one
after that I can't remember he was a
good actor though he was yeah uh [ __ ]
he was better when he was eating man
yeah he's still like more like a Suave
yeah [ __ ] yeah Boris could do
that too though now I will say and this
is no you know I'm not [ __ ] on Bella
or anything but I do think Boris Karloff
had maybe a wider range yeah
um just to the fact that he could play
lots of different kind of characters he
could play a monster he could play a
Suave [ __ ] I kind of feel like
Bella like played both of those kind of
roles but I think he was better as like
a swap yeah Baylor was a sex symbol
right his area he wasn't a monster
per se it's just that Dracula was it was
both he was the [ __ ] sex symbol and a
[ __ ] monster so he was good at that
but Bayla you'd look at him now and you
go well he's not really it wasn't the
day where Jack [ __ ] ran around
on screen all the time it wasn't about
physicality it was more about how you
delivered lines and what your facial
expressions and what you were wearing
Bella in his [ __ ] in his prime was
the [ __ ]
he was the kind of dude that would talk
his way up your woman's skirt that's
what he was yeah and he was just a sexy
foreign guy
yeah for uh where was he from I mean it
wasn't Romania I don't think was it was
uh it was Hungarian Hungaria yeah I'm
pretty sure and he was just hungry yeah
and he was just uh he was a cool dude
too
um
poor guy didn't
his his life didn't end well well I
guess it did I guess it did because his
life kind of ended with hey man rehab is
a reality you know that's how his life
ended I I will always go see for being
essentially like the first big star to
like go into rehab and like be open
about it because I think that might have
gone a long way toward like
destigmatizing that he got addicted to
painkillers and then became a junkie and
he was like
first celebrity to come out and go yeah
[ __ ] drug addiction is a reality it's
a [ __ ] yeah and go to [ __ ] rehab if
you're addicted to this yeah which was
like a big deal it was a big deal well
the thing about it is that Bella Lugosi
sadly I kind of feel like after you know
he got hugely famous with Dracula and
then he was like in a few more movies
but then like it really seemed like his
career like went on the decline whereas
Boris Karloff was like working all the
way up until like you know until he was
an old man yeah well Bayla was probably
hard to work with he was junkie that's
true he was a junkie and um he was in
his own little world but [ __ ] Karloff
didn't have that problem so he was a lot
easier to work with yeah and yeah
Karloff was like a lot more uh
professional but yeah like I said even
in the 60s if you uh you know subscribe
over at my scarce Salon Channel I've
been doing his Thriller series like from
the early 1960s
um you know he hosted that he did all
this voiceover work and stuff like that
because he has a great voice so you know
uh Hugo says fun fact there's an earlier
Frankenstein movie made by Thomas Edison
in 1910. yeah I've seen it I actually
did um a really long write-up like a
silent movie Watcher like for my um on
my uh scare Salon site like not too long
ago was it any good it's okay it's it's
not really a lot like I mean it's silent
obviously because it's 1910. and it's
pretty short if I remember correctly I
think it's like less than an hour it's
been a while since I've seen it but yeah
I wrote like a thing about it but yeah I
mean
I don't know I just I kind of feel like
of all the universal monster movies that
we've watched so far and like I said I'm
really I'm excited that we're doing all
these because I haven't seen them in
such a long time
um so it's really cool to like revisit
them we definitely have to do Dracula
because I know that's on there but who
Hugo's talking about the 1931 Spanish
Dracula versions okay well there's yeah
yeah yeah it was made with like the same
sets and everything and a lot of people
like that one better yeah and then uh
somebody mentioned in their [ __ ]
Nosferatu uh Nosferatu visually
had it it's just that it was it was a
silent flick it wasn't a talkie it would
have been a lot better if it was a
talking but you know it's before it's
time and the thing is is that your [ __ ]
ass should have never even have seen
Nosferatu they ordered that [ __ ] [ __ ]
bird destroyed destroyed you're lucky
they haven't even seen it which is uh
that's a miracle to Modern film history
that that survived
it is a good movie I've seen it
it's a silent movie
which puts it in a different Realm
it's not like a talkie
but [ __ ] tell you what man that that
vampire looked badass it did it looked
that still looks creepy as [ __ ] that
still looks creepy yeah it looks a lot
more creepy than Bella but Bella was a
speaking vampire that was the first of
the sexy vampires yeah he was like the
swab [ __ ] right yeah and that it
was a different it was a different play
on that Nosferatu looked more like like
described in the book yeah
you know which that's creepy too very
creepy
Samantha said what's that vampire movie
with Willem Dafoe and John Malkovich
shadow of the vampire but that was about
the making of Nosferatu uh also a really
good movie I was looking for that last
night because I thought I was like oh
maybe it's on 2B it's not Gods and
Monsters is on 2B which is about uh I
think Ian McKellen was in that and
that's like actually about James whale
although I don't think it's about the
making of Frankenstein I think it's
about James whale like later on in his
life
so there's that
um let's see uh they say the Dracula
1931 Spanish version yeah it was better
than Bella's I've heard that too but I
don't think I've ever seen the Spanish
version but I hear that all the time
that the Spanish version it's in Spanish
yeah
yeah I wouldn't mind seeing it it was
made like the same year and I'm pretty
sure it was made like on the same sets
and it's the same script essentially but
it was just like made for the Spanish
Market yeah yeah I can't remember the
name of the guy that played the vampire
though I've seen clips of it but I've
never seen the whole thing straight why
would people say it was better
I don't know well that's I don't know
because I haven't really seen it I've
seen clips of it but good you know I
mean the Bella Lugosi one like I said is
Iconic and I don't know if I if I'm
gonna think the other one's better or
not but but yeah so I don't know Trey's
excited because he said Frankenstein
Bride of Frankenstein are two of his
favorite movies of all time well then
hopefully you'll like our review yeah I
mean they're both great they're both
great I like them both for different
reasons it's just kind of like you said
it's like the Alien aliens thing yeah
I'm gonna say like as far as those two I
like alien the first one better because
I like the more horror thing as opposed
to like the more action thing but
they're both amazing movies the same
thing applies here I like this one I
like the first one because it's kind of
like simpler it's more like a
traditional monster movie it's like
scarier like I like the look of the
makeup better I like the fact that the
monster doesn't really talk he's more
even though he's sympathetic he's more
of an antagonist more of a monster like
a creature so I like that but the second
one I just really like the complexity of
the story I love Dr pretorius I kind of
like that
um that the monster now has like more of
a personality although it kind of like
takes away his scariness but like I said
I'm glad that they introduced Dr
pretorius as like the straight up
villain because you know otherwise the
movie wouldn't really have like a very
strong villain and it does so I think
that was like a wise decision to add
that character I'm gonna give it to
Bride of Frankenstein yeah I think it's
Superior movie a shot composition tone
of the movie it's a beautiful [ __ ]
the scenes that are in there the the
monster talking he's starting to talk
and now he's a dude he's just smoking
smoking and drinking trying to fit in
with everybody else thinking [ __ ]
with it
and then he's not so much the villain
yeah he's a threatening guy but he's
sympathetic
and then then pretorius comes in a guy
messing with his own jizz yeah to make
creatures growing tiny people with jizz
in jars right that's that's weird [ __ ]
and um no and just the budget of the
movie the internal shots of the [ __ ]
Castle Dracula with the vaulted ceilings
and just it was a bigger better movie
more Gothic you know the graveyard
scenes down in the catacombs
it had a a Gothic Gestalt to it that is
like yeah that's that's [ __ ]
Frankenstein that's it you know
an undead living man made out of [ __ ]
body parts running around inside of a
cemetery and down in a crypt and
drinking and eating down there and
there's [ __ ] skulls and he's talking
to a mad scientist who's messing with
jizz [ __ ] yeah that's it
that's it yeah [ __ ] messing with
jizz
and then they're going to make a [ __ ]
beautiful woman
out of body parts using the damn bones
of an 18 year old that died in the 1800s
they're gonna put some badass meat on it
put it an artificial braid in the heart
of a hooker and she comes out and she's
the perfect woman bubitude and
everything like a mummy and [ __ ] with
her freaky ass [ __ ]
industrial [ __ ] haircut [ __ ] it it's
like something about the [ __ ] goth
industrial [ __ ] club and she comes
out and she doesn't like the monster no
she likes Dr Frankenstein she just
pisses and screams yeah yeah she's she
knows hot when she sees it she's like
she don't like she's that motherfucker's
ugly she likes this guy over here he's
cute you know it's no that's it that's
the [ __ ] move okay that's the [ __ ]
movie I'm gonna give it to a number I'm
gonna give it to part two
the hair by the way was I didn't even
realize this but the hair by the way was
actually inspired by that uh very famous
bust of Nefertiti yeah where she has
that it was a headdress yeah that's what
they I see it now yeah like Nefertiti
yeah I didn't I didn't think of that but
I was like oh yeah now that you
mentioned well she's definitely in mummy
wraps yeah definitely yeah when they
when they when they pull her out of
there out of there what I was gonna say
too because here's something that you
pointed out
while we were watching the movie is that
it seems to be set in the 1800s but also
in the Contemporary time like I said it
was made like in the 1930s yeah it's not
in it that was a deliberate Choice
apparently by James whale um I think
that the studio wanted it to be set in
the present day which then would have
been the 1930s but he kind of wanted to
do almost like an alternate universe
type of thing where you would have like
um Incorporated the both time periods so
that's what you were saying you're like
well you look like everyone looks like
they're dressed from the 1930s but then
and then there's like scientific [ __ ]
from like the 1930s but then there's
stuff that's like from the 1800s yeah
and you were just kind of like well they
didn't what year is this they just
[ __ ] that up or whatever but yeah he
deliberately did it made it in this kind
of like liminal space it's in its own
Universe it's in its own universe so
yeah he did do that on purpose and the
first one
um he did that the first one too
although I think it's less obvious
because in the second one like it stood
out all the peasants are in the 1800s
hundreds
they dug they got that body in the 1800s
but a lot of the main characters are
dressed in the early 1900s right
and uh the technology is [ __ ] 1700
sometimes uh or the architecture
sometimes 17 1500s but then sometimes
you have stuff from like that was
contemporary like the early 20th yeah
and then a car goes by
in the first one I think the first one
had cars in it didn't it
maybe I'm pretty sure there's an
automobile in the first one yeah but
then in the second one too you have like
a you know horse-drawn camera strong
carriages and you're like what year is
this right yeah it's not in a year yeah
it's not anything but like I said I
didn't realize but I was reading
something earlier today that said that
he did that deliver okay like because he
wanted to kind of like have the feel of
the book which was published in 1818.
yeah written in 1816 and published in
1818. but he also wanted it to be like
contemporary with it because they show
Mary Shelley and she's talking to dudes
and they're dressed from the early 1800s
that's Napoleonic era well that's
supposed to be Lord Byron and Percy
Shelley so that's supposed to be 18 16.
because that's they're referring to the
haunted summer when she wrote the novel
and then later on you see stuff and it's
still 1800s but
and then she just explained it it's in a
mythical time period yeah don't don't
worry about it yeah I'm I'm trying to
estimate what year this is based on
[ __ ] the clothes and the things that
I'm seeing
and no it's a mythical time period
it's it's just it's Gothic times yeah
it's Gothic time yeah it didn't stand
out to me too much but I think it stood
out more in the second one yeah so I
could see what you were saying but right
I didn't know if it was a deliberate
choice or not but I was reading
something earlier that said it was
deliberating okay because they wouldn't
they would have known it was deliberate
back then yeah because they know they
would have known what was normal
yeah because yeah I mean honestly like
in the early 1930s it's like you know
the 1800s wasn't really that long ago so
you know what I mean they would have
been a lot more they're run around
Castle Dracula doing high-tech [ __ ] and
I'm going wait hold on that's not 1930s
technology that's not even 20s
this before all that it's all mythical
yeah that's what they're doing
but that's you know fair enough yeah
Danny Rowling said a human steampunk
mech suit Frankenstein of an old-timey
freak Show giant corpse reanimate it
would be cool to see yeah that's very
specific but you're right that that
would actually be really cool Hugo said
I prefer nosferatuo overbella anytime
I'm more of a creature guy
I mean yeah I'm the nosferati like that
is more um book accurate like at least
the look of it but I like them both you
know you know what I was saying
feed Tom feed Toms Frankenstein hungry
for grub and it's feeding time it
probably is are you are you hungry I'm
getting there you oh okay I thought it
was probably about time yeah powered by
a [ __ ] genius that makes it even
better it's like a little petty person
that would be cool like I don't know if
somebody like built that or you know
what I mean but yeah that would be
pretty awesome and Trey said I just
realized I'm wearing a Frankenstein
t-shirt today we'll see there you go we
didn't even like mean to well what
happened was we watched the first
Frankenstein like a few nights ago
and then last night I think we watched
Bride of Frankenstein oh my phone just
made a noise
probably maybe I got a text or something
I'm not really sure
um and I was like well you know what why
why don't we just because because it was
like several days ago that we watched
the first Frankenstein it was like I
didn't remember it as good as like Bride
of Frankenstein which we just watched
last night so I was like let's just
combine them because if I if I try to do
them like separately I'm just gonna
we're just gonna end up talking about
them both anyway yeah let's talk about
them so I figure we'll do we'll do part
three on its own but we're probably
gonna move on to [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
Creature from the Black Lagoon probably
would be the next yeah we can either do
like for Tuesday well tomorrow's Monday
so we're gonna do a haunting tomorrow
but Tuesday I mean we could either do
the original Dracula or we could do
Creature From The Blacklist you want a
Dracula okay yeah yeah yeah that would
be a good problem yeah okay because
there I know for sure that those are
both on 2B so we can watch those both I
haven't seen Dracula in a long time I
haven't either I've seen it a bunch of
times but I saw it a bunch of times when
I was a kid so I probably haven't seen
it like in a really long time but yeah
so um as I said if you have if you're in
the US I'm not sure about other
countries 2B has a lot of the universal
monster movies like on there for free so
you can go on there including they're
worth two and they're definitely worth
seeing if you haven't seen them like
especially if you're under horror I kind
of feel like if you're young and you've
never seen these old classics it kind of
behooves you to see them all right
they're part of History they're part of
your culture doesn't matter where you
are in the world either
uh [ __ ] even in the Middle East or
[ __ ] Asia these movies should be
appreciated because they ended up
contributing to a global culture that
people [ __ ] know about this is where
the [ __ ] came from you know I mean it
was from these movies
and they're good they're good and I feel
like when you think about Frankenstein's
monster
most of the stuff if you ask like just a
random [ __ ] in the street about
frankincense monster most of the stuff
they would say about it would be from
the movies not So Much from the book
yeah because I feel like the book isn't
as widely read and so a lot of people if
you talk about that they're talking
about the monster or the or the movies
more than the novel and there's a lot of
they played on this a lot the same thing
I mean this same theme there was [ __ ]
that came out recently that was based on
this that I [ __ ] love like I love
Frankenstein's Army which I think is
Russian or was it German
that could have been German I think yeah
Frankenstein's Army was great it was it
was about World War II was it I think
was that an asylum movie I think it
might have been I don't know it was
[ __ ] crazy it wasn't I liked it it
was it was a super fun yeah if you
haven't seen Frankenstein's Army yeah
I'm [ __ ] crazy and it's real gory you
know
let's see uh Danny Rowling said what's
tomorrow's a haunting episode gonna be
we'll probably do the possessed because
I think that you wanted us to do that
one yeah it would probably do the
possess so we'll probably do the possess
I think we watched it a couple weeks ago
but I don't think we have reviewed it
yet one big couple hamburgers and then
we'll get on that all right so we'll do
that so hopefully you guys uh had a good
time to listen is talking about oh
Universal monster movies and we'll be
back tomorrow 6 p.m Eastern Standard
Time doing our haunting Mondays probably
it'll be the possessed if I change my
mind I'll you know I'll post about it
tomorrow at some point so have a good
rest of your weekend everybody and we'll
see you guys again tomorrow evening good
night